what up guys welcome to the just curly
things youtube channel
today i am going to eat lunch with you
while i react
to kevin samuels the title of the video
is called
this happens way too often with modern
women
i'm a woman in the modern era so let's
see does it happen to me
i don't know let me know in the comments
um and don't forget to like comment and
subscribe
i'm trying to get to 15 000 so
okay
okay she i'm gonna just start by saying
she's not like she doesn't look super
overweight and unattractive which seems
to be like
a common theme with the women that that
call into history okay
you're gonna get your workout on look at
you thank you it's what i do
there you go so what do you have for me
there's two times you're talking about
settling or dying alone or the goldman
sachs 10 billion dollars into a million
black women what do you want to attack
let's do the settling and dying alone
all right you've heard you've heard what
i have to say about a lot of stuff what
do you think about it
i agree and i disagree okay i want to
say that last conversation was really
good you really had me thinking um
the whole fear protection
that's what i know a lot of me and my
friends are looking for
not to throw myself under the bus but
i'm 30.
we all something
and i am a nurse practitioner in the
emergency department
a lot of my friends are professionals
and we're doing well
but we are single
chronically nurses are single anything
else
i'm surprised you think nurses would be
like
pretty good like moms you know like
they're like nurturing and stuff what
you think so
yeah ma'am uh actually i did a broadcast
talking about the kind of women that
high value men typically don't date
and nurses were in that category really
for for a multitude of reasons but
what's funny
is go back 80 years ago and nursing was
some of the most
feminine work you could do
i can see that um typically
but i can see that now well today's
nurses
work really long hours those twelve
three
three days a week 12 on 12 months
high stress i mean there's a lot of
things that go into it but
at 30 years old do you have any children
no okay
and what region are you in north east
south i am southern
okay and if you don't i'm just trying to
respect your
geographic uh privacy at 30 years old
you said me and my friends
are all kind of doing the same thing
what are some of the issues you're
finding when you personally
are trying to date before that do you
want to get married
i do do you want children i do how many
would you like to have
at least one or two don't have one have
two or none
only children that's a horrible way to
be raised okay so
i would be your mom and dad they were
okay so what do you what are you running
into
um people at least where i am i feel
like are not ready to settle
um from like a previous guy watched of
yours you talked about
the age difference men tend to get in
their career
or especially black men because you
start trying to get our money right
before we want to get married and have
kids
so i'm 30 i've been at that point
but some are still not there yet so
what's the oldest man you ever did
um
how old i would say closer to my age
like 32.
okay so that's one of the issues so the
comment section is off it's just you and
me talking
okay good yeah i don't do that
um age gap dating
one thing that i don't think a lot of
women have been told
is that men our brains don't really
turn on until age 30. okay
yours turned on around 20. ours turned
on
i mean the light is just now on click
the lights on
between the 20 and 30 we don't know [ __ ]
i call it the twinkling 20s the more the
closer i got to 30 tomorrow i realized i
didn't know anything in my 20s
between 30 and 35 this is where most men
who are productive competitively
successful
are starting to determine what kind of
wife
or family they would like to have if any
i really i would agree i don't think
women are told like
i never thought about dating older when
i was like
20 21 you know and i also
like
would agree that like your brain kind of
shifts when you hit like
for me it was like 21 but you kind of
shift out of like the like i don't know
crazy phase so to speak i personally
don't feel like men
in this country are ready for marriage
until they're 35 years old
and then at that age a 35 year old man
should be looking for a woman between
the ages of 21 and 26.
and that's what i'm thinking because
i've watched your previous lives
but if as we know jerry actually
pregnant
c is 35. that's you exactly
so y'all if you want to get married
you're a man
a man who's be ready to be married have
a family
and if it's anything close to a
traditional stuff that i'm bringing
talk about a man who's at least 40 years
old
and see dating men who are close to your
age
may feel like you got more in common
but there's a level of respect a woman
needs to have for a man
in order to follow him and it's hard to
look at your
peer somebody that's a year too older to
you
with the same level of respect it's also
difficult for men to have acquired the
kind of resources the wisdom the
experience
to adequately manage shepherd and
administer a wife and family
okay so correct me if i'm wrong
but i'm i believe that marriages are
more successful like statistically if
they're closer in
age like when there's a higher age gap
they're a lot more likely to get
divorced
so if that's true
i wonder why kevin samuels is
encouraging that or let me know in the
comments i could look it up but
you guys know me i'm just watching
i get what you're saying but then at the
same time i feel like
i've done those things so i would expect
my counterparts to kind of be there as
well
so what age
i know mentally it may take
over 30 like you said 32 35.
men have it i'm just saying what i'm
saying i think maybe maybe you miss what
i'm saying
men have those things they just don't
get it until later in life
so you want to date somebody roughly
your age
roughly yes um i can't
i can't change biology he said that's
the problem see now we're going to have
a problem
no absolutely i cannot make men mature
or evolve
any faster than do throughout history
women have always matured earlier than
men
today in the modern world men are
required to do far more than our fathers
grandfathers and great-grandfathers
so people are getting married later
what is the problem dating somebody in
their late
30s or 40.
i don't see one i have not been
approached by someone
okay but but if you were what's the
issue
there's not um
are you sure because what is a 40 year
old man to you look like in your mind
why is this glitching out hold up guys
i think it's the video
uh-oh okay so
you say you don't see one all right
um do you want to share what what's the
nearest big city you live in
next to memphis tennessee all right
which has
population of 500 to 700 000.
um this is when it becomes a math
equation
you got to look at the kind of lifestyle
you want to have
the kind of man that would make the kind
of income to help facilitate the
lifestyle you want to have
how much work you want to have to do to
support the family if any
because the problem is many women today
are looking for men the kind of kind of
men and
they're not in your area it's like
i was talking to somebody earlier this
week and they were in a remote part in
the northeast and i'm like
that's that's where you go after you
marry
i can't make men pop up in a
a population of less than 400 000.
and that's probably part of my problem
because as far as finance and everything
else
i'm i'm fine with it and myself the
upbringing i
find the whole submissive like that's
how i was raised
but what city are you i am in
south haven which is close to
memphis it's maybe 20 minutes away okay
so
effectively memphis now you got to know
just like i know
memphis is rather colorful when it comes
to dating
it is so
um
you might want to consider moving
because long distance relationships
don't really work this is when i this is
where i have become
ruthlessly pragmatic far too many women
today
are doing what men traditionally have
done i go where the work is i mean why
am i working there because that's why i
got my job off
but if you had had a but if you've been
thinking about
but yeah but do i want to be married and
have kids and so far then how am i going
to be found by my husband if i'm living
in a place with 150 000 people that's
the dating pool
think about the high school you went to
that's who you can date from versus when
you if you go to college you get all
those people
that's true so if you and your
friends are being unsuccessful is
because you're all competing for the
same very small
pool understand one reason
so at 30 years old if you're a nurse
can't you move to dallas houston you can
do what you do in a big city
i can um i mean i've traveled and i mean
i'm willing to move
uh be a nurse practitioner in ed i can
work everywhere
well what i'm saying is and what i'm
also saying is
black women are going to have to get
very
pragmatic and competitive i mean
start you know when becky them wants
something
they go find it they'll they'll go sit
in history class because he
has history class at that time she just
want to be next to him
and too many black women just expect it
just to happen nope
because we're already y'all already
outnumber us she's
very um like agreeable like all
of the women i've seen like on this have
been very like unruly and very like they
don't listen at all but this is actually
a really interesting conversation
where he's not just telling her that
it's over because she's 30.
i think i had this expectation
especially being a southern woman and
traditional
i want the man to be at least assertive
enough to approach me so i know he wants
me
and me chase him well
uh scarlett o'hara also had to be in
proximity of it but
he did not have to go dig her up or find
her
but i feel like that's part of that
scammer society that's that southern
bell i want you for this reasons like
my point is if you want a man to
court you you have to be in his
proximity
uh he ain't gonna court you from atlanta
and you're in memphis he gonna go
over to midtown we're gonna see that's
the thing
you ladies know how to organize a life
a career but when it gets to your
relationships and your
your romantic life it's like i just want
the dream and the fantasy and lesbian
nebulous no no no no no
when you went to college there was a
curriculum you know you had 100
x hours to complete and my freshman
assault my freshman
i had to do this this this this this
just like you work out right you don't
just go to the gym and say i want a good
body
no there's there's a workout regimen it
changes often there's a diet
there's a lot that goes into being you
well the kind of man you want is he
valuable
yes is he rare probably
well then you gonna have to work
or or
bye dog
because the reality is this is what
happens see it's easy to stick your head
down
and work and see right around 30 is when
a lot of times
see a lot of times when women black
women in particular
in the black community when we break up
and have relationships things fall apart
once one of the first things we tend to
want to do is go back to school
go back to get more education that's why
i find so many sisters who are engaged
and got masters
and all you're doing is wasting two more
years you're 30 years old
are you about to go back to school i
actually am but
i feel like i have that
by night you can't make this up
because you don't have extra time listen
to that tick tock
that's your biological clock ticking and
i feel like
myself available you feel like what
i make myself and as i said career path
i
choose is always flexible okay see
you can be pragmatic in your career path
but in your emotional life it's all
about your feelings
don't tell me about what you feel tell
me about what you think show me the
numbers
you're going to all girls college and
you're looking for a husband
no tell me about what you feel you see
what i said
when life starts to slow down first
thing a lot of black hole i want to do
i'ma go back to school so i can stick my
head in the sand
and feel like i'm getting something
accomplished in life so i'm gonna do
this
bro i ain't got no husbands let me let
me go over here
i can't understand my thinking and then
i'm gonna look up
and two years of gone by then then
what's what happens i got an
ms or nba then i showcase
a guy who just graduated from high
school because there's too much of an
educational gap
no i totally disagree with like
i don't think going to college makes you
smarter than other people i think some
of the smartest people like my dad
he's extremely successful and he did not
go to college oh no no no that's not
what i'm doing this is like three
semesters postmasters
postmasters uh huh i'm a phd
i'm phd i don't mean to say it like that
but what i'm saying is i'm saying it
like that because
i'll be available i think it is i think
it is a travesty to have so many
attractive
educated intelligent chronically single
black women because
you refuse to act like
your non-black counterparts you refuse
to be competitive refuse to understand
that the sexual marketplace
requires you to compete for men i don't
have a colleague his name is dr tia son
johnson he teaches black masculine
studies university california santa
barbara
one of the two places in the country
that teaches about black men
and you know what he told me one of the
largest enrollees in his class
used to be white women he used to
fascinate him until he asked why are you
here
at least i didn't ask some of these
college students like i like black men
my boyfriend's black i want to learn
about the black culture to be a better
woman for my man
you know who's not in that class you
becky's there to learn how to be a
better woman to a black man but you just
expect black men to show up
now hispanic women are starting to show
up because other women are coming for
your men because other women
have heard that y'all don't compete for
your man if you just leave
your treasure out there so then you get
mad when the kardashians
when the ballers end up gone with becky
why he made a white woman because you
think it's self-hate
no you're not it's because those women
actually showed some interest
and came around and actually acted like
they care they just sit back like you
need to come court me
my black men get with non black women
this is funny because
i'm dating an entertainer that i made
the first move on
i i feel i feel weird because they hate
themselves
most black men who are with non-black
women will tell you they love black
women their first choice would be a
black one
but being with a black woman in general
is too complex
and then you tell that to a sister where
we worked it such and so forth and all
that sounds good
until
[Music]
you thirty you got choices you got
thirty you gonna burn three semesters
three semesters of this very valuable
five year period
why um i think
it's a good choice career choice
especially with the pen
okay and then the skill allowed me to be
very flexible and be able to work anyway
so i don't think it would hinder
okay okay well i would tell you that i
know many women who went back to school
uh and i i think they would beg to
differ i think they would tell you that
being in school you can't serve two
masters you got to have a job and then
you're in school
you have no time to really devote to a
man
paging doctor where's she at where they
at i wish i could i wish i could bring
them up right now
i'm telling you i'm just talking i do a
lot of research
just think about what i'm saying between
30 and 35 are critical years
and you're dedicating nine you did three
semesters so that's a year and a half
you're going to want to get some return
from that year and a half investment
but at the end of the day let's say you
what you found your husband or your
husband found you
you won't have to work to pay
significant bills after you're pregnant
i mean i don't want to miss you
do you want to have to work to pay
significant bills after you're pregnant
i don't want to know okay what
percentage of
what percentage of the family financial
load do you want to
have to carry for a lifetime out of 100
what percentage do you want to be
responsible for having to make
i don't have that exact answer i mean i
want to be out of 100
right now you got a pair 100 of your
financial load if you get married and
you have two kids what percentage is
that financial load do you want to have
to carry
i don't know the way i've always thought
about it being that i love that
traditional
i would love to have a man that would
want to do that and pay the major bills
but i know i will always heal
so okay so so
so i feel like 20 30 what you're
ultimately saying is i don't
want to have to carry any of it i would
help
but i want him to be able to pay 100 of
everything
at least the major stuff i want to give
him no no man
man when i say the okay the mortgage the
car notes
the insurance the retirement the kids
college fund
all that stuff is something what
percentage of that do you want to have
to be responsible for
and i was asking what do you want to i
would rather
my husband if god lets me have one to
pay mortgage
this ain't about god this is a natural
choice i'm a christian but this is
not ain't got no part in our failures
down here well
the major bills i would prefer my
husband to pay just to have that have a
household growth so in other words ma'am
you want a husband that's going to
take they can fund that can afford to
cover you
two kids to where your money is
discretionary
i would hell with the kids no i wouldn't
i'm talking about the finances of the
family
okay he's asked the same question like
five times i'm not talking about the
administering of the family
see this is a question that so many
black women don't think about
than math of it because the next part
is coming home you said i don't want to
have to work
after the patient never get those out
that i'm pregnant that means your
husband has to pay
all the significant bills if you're not
working well then why is she going back
to school
right i think i missed with it i don't
mind working
is no okay but it's part but one percent
okay but i'm gonna need to be real clear
you have to pay 100 of your lifestyle
right now
after you're married with two children
what percentage of your family's
lifestyle do
you want to have to pay
i don't want to say 50 50 just for shits
and giggles let's do
75 25. 75 is going to who
you know yes all right
that's what i guess 20 to 30 that means
if the mortgage was two thousand dollars
that means he's paying fifteen hundred
and you're paying five hundred
if he got listen listen listen
25 i think what she's trying
to say is like she'd be open to like
other arrangements but like obviously
she'd prefer he pay for
the majority or all of it but like if a
guy could only pay like 50 or like 75
she'd be fine with that too it's a nice
tip
so what you're basically saying is i
want a man
who can pay damn near 80 percent of the
entire
family financial of the mortgage the car
payment the insurance retirement trips
to travel to braces
everything man you said 75 25
i don't wanna stop stop stop stop it
doesn't matter
how precise you get it the bottom line
is you don't want it to be 50 50.
but here's okay so so so
listen this is important
ready that means this career you're
talking about
you're going to give it up anyway
because the real career is your husband
he's going to be bringing in all the
money if you get the man
you want he's going to be the major
bread winner
you are not going to be responsible so
this extra degree extra thing
is all actually not going to an
outcome it's just sitting on the wall
you think so man if you have a
husband that's what i just said paying
75
of everything and you're paying 25
you are not in a career you got a job
he's carrying the lion's share so why do
you need a masters or anything else like
that to cover
25 no no
because this is what so many sisters
don't do
they just go talk about jobs and careers
in this but when it gets right down to
it
i really don't want to have to be the
one responsible for the financial load
i hope god blesses me with a man that i
can be and that's fine
so start with the end in mind
you don't want to have to be the bread
winner you only want to be 50 50.
but see the thing is you got to get the
man
first or the scenario you want
i get what you're saying let me play my
case the type of jobs that i go after
the reason why i want to do that because
it allows me to be what they call prn
so i work as i know a period oh but i
still make a really good income
so it allows me very effective like i
can date
so where's your money gonna go now even
though
it sounds terrible what you're saying
it's not sounds terrible it sounds
accurate
it sounds like most women don't want to
have to be
responsible for the financial family
load they want it on their husband
so if that's the case you don't need
a career you need a you
you need enough money to cover
25 and that's not an mba
a master's anything else you could work
anywhere and cover 25
but see so many women think i'll do all
this
and and i'm assuming you're taking out
loans to pay for this stuff
not this summer room how much how much
long how much student loan debt did you
take out
did you have an issue you just really
got telling all my videos because
because because here's the thing
if if at the end of the day you
find the man god has for you
here you go honey i've got a bachelor's
i've got a master's and i've got this
all this debt there you go here's the
mortgage
here's the and here's the kids here's
all this
you pay all that now i got this 25
you got that now i've got the bachelor's
and the masters and all this other stuff
but i'm
actually practically responsible for
this portion of it
then you don't need it i know you don't
want to get into the specifics but a
major
like the sound of that is because i want
my
significant other to have that head of
household so if it makes him feel
like better doing that or if that's
something i can't allow him to do just
to have that
traditional role i want him to do that
for his family i want him to be able to
pay the mortgage
what do you mean he has no problem
helping him
no no no no no you're a southern woman
let's be real you don't want to marry a
man have two kids and you're paying 50
of the bills not the whole time like i
would rather that's the point than stop
stop
then you need to understand how much is
good see
this is where not having a family plan
what kind of man would you need what
kind of
income would you need a man to make to
be able to support the kind of lifestyle
you want for your kids and your family
to where your employment is flexible
because here's the reality
if you never marry you got to pay a
hundred percent
but this is why ladies this whole notion
of dying alone or settling
one way you're paying 100 of everything
by your damn self
so i don't care if you love i don't care
if the dick is good
if the man is doing what he's supposed
to do you need to realize you lucky to
have somebody to settle for
because at 30 years old i know
emotionally what you want
but i think you can be i think it's fair
to say practically
you've not really sat down and thought
about the math of it
thought about the actual t's and eyes of
it it's always been me me me
me me me me and then oh well
that's the guy who's making two hundred
thousand dollars 250
today
[Music]
i'm pretty simplistic um but i get what
you're saying
okay pretty simple do you want to live
in a house yes
um how much
how much do you think it would cost to
live in memphis
for a family of four middle class to
where your kids could
go to a nice public school okay he
always says these absurd
numbers that
like poor kids exist in middle class
the private school where they can get
braces
join all the clubs all the stuff that
most middle class folks will do
go to college if necessary how much
would a man need to make
i haven't added that up well you tell me
what do you think
i don't know about memphis i know in the
country
where i'm at you can get a good acre
and a nice dc but if they have good
public schools
good private schools no they don't they
do okay man
roughly the numbers about 300 thousand
dollars because memphis ain't that
different than atlanta and the cost of
living
and the fact of the matter you just said
it i i haven't thought of that
that means you haven't thought about the
actual man
or the resources required to facilitate
this dream
this hope this goal you would have what
kind of man
income would he need to make to be able
to
let your income be variable let you not
have to work to pay significant bills
once you're pregnant
let me after you have your baby do you
want to have to go back to work
after 12 weeks or do you want to be able
to stay home with your child for
the first year or two i feel like this
is boiling down to finances
because because we're grown-ups and life
does boil down to finances
i asked you a question do you want to
have to after 12 weeks of fmla do you
want to have to go back to the hospital
or do you want to be able to stay at
home and raise your child
i would think most women would say like
me they would ask for you
oh wow but yeah i will go back to work
okay what do you want man
see see but what you which i know what
she's trying to say she's trying to say
like
if i can find a guy making that amount
of money yeah that's what i'd prefer but
like i don't mind going to work
this is another thing i don't understand
why black women act like
money is not something to be considered
it has to be thought about all right but
i'm i know i'm not going to be able to
be a homemaker and i'm okay with it i
didn't say be a homemaker i said do you
want to have to after 12 weeks of fmla
do you want to have to turn your child
over to a daycare
and you go back to that go back to work
or do you want to have
the ability to stay at home in a perfect
world no
but i wouldn't know which one is it
it's that if i have the option from the
man that i was with
make it simple which one do you want
i want to work how about that i want to
work i enjoy what i do
you want to work i enjoy you want to
work okay cool
how much is infant child care
monthly i don't have the answer to that
ballpark what do you think
infant child care um
in a month a year um it's going to be
a couple thousand yep so while you go
back to work
after 12 weeks you can write off at
least 500
a month for your baby to go to daycare
to be raised and careful by
whoever in the corona daycare
instead of you at home with your baby
doing what you're doing
i grew up i grew up with nannies it's
not that bad that's 24 000 dollars taken
out of the family just like that that's
before pampers and everything else
and then when you have another baby
because you're not gonna say well you
have two
you're gonna have one in three years old
or two years old and another one
this is why you guys you ladies gotta
start thinking about this
infant child care is expensive daycare
is expensive
you find that you have a a one or two
year old and an infant in daycare
that may be fully 50 percent of your
salary
so if that's the case you have to have
it and
black women hear me hear me well
i need to learn about the men and learn
about the math
because just acting like you just acting
like it doesn't exist or to take care of
itself
it does come down to money and we don't
talk about money in the black community
not enough it's like tacky and we can go
but then they were mad when [ __ ] don't
work out
you get mad if you're living in an
apartment
and having to work like a mad woman you
know that stars
like you don't ask nobody how much they
making or no
way the thing is not other cultures
don't do that they do this
because here's the net net of bottom
line is this
you want your husband to make more to
you
because he's gonna have to carry the
bulk of the financial load and you know
how much you make
what percentage of men in this country
make more than 75
what percentage of black men earn more
than 75 thousand dollars
not a lot 15 and then in
podunk america
that's what i'm saying so it comes down
to i'm passionate about this because
so many black women are just out there
just like well
i got me together and i'm doing me and
i'm like well yeah but
you want a man to be all these things
and
you need to know who he is what he needs
to do how much he needs to earn and
let's go all the way back to the
beginning
men earn the kind of money you're
talking about aren't 30 years old
they're men earned are in the peak of
their financial income
at 45 to 55 not 32.
i understand so this is a good call
because all the things you may want
think
when you have to have them challenged
when you and your girlfriends are
sitting down talking about this i would
almost guarantee
they'll never get this specific but this
granular it's all in this
what i would like to have and possible
okay fine
but here's the thing let's move it down
the path
the very men that you or your
girlfriends would want
they want something to what do they want
from a woman
and see if you haven't even identified
who these men are
what they do how much they make such and
so forth that means
you damn sure can't tell me what they
want from a woman
so how do you expect for these two
things to come together
this was really interesting um a lot of
stuff that i really never thought about
in terms of like child care and like
money and stuff
like planning a family but okay the way
he talks though one caveat i have is
like
he acts like poor people can't have and
raise
kids and you shouldn't have any kids
unless you make
350 400k a year you guys tell me that i
misunderstand him a lot so
if that's wrong let me know but um don't
forget to like comment and subscribe
thanks for watching the video guys bye